(logo whooshing)
(bright music)
(dramatic music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Samuel
Bowles, who is Research Professor
and chairman of the program
in Behavioral Sciences
at the Santa Fe Institute
in Santa Fe New Mexico.
He's a prolific writer,
having published articles
in many magazines and journals
and his most recent book is
The Moral Economy:
Why Good Laws are no
Substitute for Good Citizens.
Sam, welcome to Berkeley.
- It's great to be here, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well I was born in
New Haven, Connecticut
but I was raised pretty
much all over the place
because my parents lived
different parts of the country,
Washington D.C. during
the Second World War,
spent a lot of time in India
as a kid, going to school there
and other parts of the world.
- Your father was U.S.
Ambassador to India.
Before we talk about that,
tell me what what you
learned from your parents
and how they informed your
perspective on the world.
- Well I would say, Harry,
that my mom and my dad
were Liberal Democrats.
They were secular, they
were not religious people
but they had very strong values
about how we ought to
interact with each other.
And they passed those values
on to me very strongly.
- And was there a lot of
discussion about politics
and world affairs around the dinner table
as it moved from place to place?
- Well I think you could say
that you couldn't really
talk about anything else.
(both laughing)
Even from a young age that's
what got you airtime is
to have an opinion about something
and so I've been doing that
ever since I was pretty young.
- And how old were you
when your father was
U.S. Ambassador to India?
- I was 11 when I went to
India and 13 when I came back.
I missed junior high school,
that wasn't a bad to miss.
(both laughing)
- Especially if you were
prepared for the new economy.
And how did the experience
in India affect you?
- Well, you can imagine.
I came from a small town
in eastern Connecticut.
I went to an elementary
school that had four rooms.
I was starting off in a high school
that had never sent anyone
to an Ivy League college
despite the fact that we were right next
to Yale and Brown and Harvard and so on.
When I went to India,
it was obviously shocking to me.
I saw people literally
in the process of dying
because of their adverse circumstances
and lack of material support
and that isn't something I knew about.
I mean in my hometown there
were exactly two poor families
and everybody knew why they were poor,
one had an alcohol problem,
one had some mental difficulties.
We knew all that, because
we went to school together.
And then all of a sudden you go to India
and it seems like everybody's poor
or the vast majority of people are poor.
That had a huge impact on me.
But also I didn't have
any American friends there
because I went to a school in which
my two sisters and I were the
only non-Indian kids there.
And so you know what
11 year olds are like.
They make friends pretty easily
and you know I was pretty
scared the first day
I went to school because I thought,
well this is a little strange.
But it wasn't strange at all
and as soon as I learned
that a football was round
and instead of being like
a football in America
and then you know got
over some of the things,
you know, I made a lot of friends.
And having close friendships,
your only friendships be with people
from a different culture is,
obviously I didn't think
about that at the time.
These were just my friends.
But thinking that way about people
who actually are quite different from you
in some ways really, really helped a lot
to open my eyes to the world.
And after, and I lived a
lot of time in Africa too,
in West Africa and I think just growing up
with people who were
of a different religion
or different point of view just
made a big difference to me.
- Yeah, given what your father was doing
there must have been a lot of interaction
even though what you
were one with notables
both in the Kennedy administration
and in Indian politics.
- The first time he was
ambassador there was under Truman
and yes, he
and my mom did become friends
with a number of notable Indians
and I remember very well going to tea
at Jawaharlal Nehru's was home,
he was prime minister at the time.
And of course even at age
11 he was one of my heroes.
I'd read all about him.
And I was so amazed when
he asked my sister and I,
wouldn't we have a look around the house.
We're having tea in the garden
and he took us even to his bedroom
and on the table next to his bed
was a picture of a poem
and the poem was Robert Frost's
and it was with the final passage,
and I have promises to keep
and miles to go before I sleep.
And, of course, coming from New England
which was where Robert Frost was from,
I was so struck by that,
that this guy from India,
who was a very erudite man,
chose to put that on his bedside table.
And when my dad, my late
father, wrote his memoirs
the title of the book is Promises to Keep
which actually, I reminded him
that Nehru had that on his bedside table.
And my dad was a big New
Englander so he liked it a lot.
- And your father was also in
the Kennedy administration.
Did he go back to India then?
- [Samuel] Yeah.
- But you were already
off to school by then.
- Yeah, yes I was in college at the time.
I was actually in grad school at the time.
- So this is an indicator of,
in a way of your future research,
because your research
and your writings are very much embedded
in a multicultural perspective.
You really emphasize what we have to learn
from other places in the world.
- Yeah, well I mean,
I'm an example of that.
I learned a tremendous
amount both in Nigeria,
I also spent a good amount of time
in the Soviet Union under communism
and yeah it became part of what I knew
and what I knew how to do in the world.
But the thing I think
which affected me most was,
imagine like I'm going to this school,
the school by the way doesn't
have a single building.
It's just old army surplus
tents and there's 2,000 kids.
- And this is where now in India?
- In India, in India.
- In India, yeah.
- It's called the Delhi Public School.
It's now a famous school.
At the time it didn't have any buildings.
And I pretty quickly understood
that I was actually pretty average
and I was average in sports
and I was maybe not even average
in some of the academic
subjects because as I say
where I'd gone to school
was not a great school
in my hometown.
And I mean I'd been interested
in other things really
but I what I found is I was kind of okay.
And then it struck me
that when I went to school
and came home on my bike what
I saw was abject poverty.
And one day I went to my
mom and I said listen,
I'm doing okay in school I'm
okay, but I'm really not.
I can't do anything really better
than most of the Indian kids
and how come the Indian people are so poor
if we're just the same as them.
And now that's a question
that's, you know,
it's kind of an interesting
question from an 11-year-old
but of course there it was.
It was staring me in the face.
I was average but they were,
I mean let's get the facts straight.
Americans at the time were 20 times richer
on average than Indians.
So what could make up that difference?
My mom, who was a former social worker,
and never lost an opportunity
to teach me a lesson or two,
she said something about colonialism.
I don't recall exactly the answer.
I don't remember thinking it
really explained very much.
Today I think it might explain
a lot more than I did then.
But that question stuck with me.
I kept asking it in various
ways, asking other people
and after, I mean after a long time,
that is after I graduated
from undergraduate college,
- [Harry] And you went to Yale.
- I went to Yale
I didn't go to grad school after that
because I was thinking of going into law
but I wasn't sure that was for me.
So I took a job teaching school
in a remote part of Nigeria,
the far northeastern part of Nigeria
on the edge of the desert.
And when I was there I, of
course, was once again confronted
by the vast poverty and
deprivation of people
who, I mean there I was a
teacher, and the students
in my classes were
extremely talented people.
And so once again I asked
myself, what's going on here?
And one night I remember
exactly when it was,
I decided I'm not gonna be a lawyer
I'm gonna be a teacher.
I didn't decide to be an economist,
I decided that I wanted to teach
'cause I was really enjoying
the classroom a lot.
And I had not a good experience
with economics as an undergrad.
I'd taken one course in it
and it had been more or less
like an immunization shot.
I got a little sick because of that course
but I knew I'd never come
down with the disease.
So I was essentially immune to economics.
But my experiences as a young man
in my early 20s convinced me
that I'd better study up on economics
because it was pretty important.
And I also thought at the time,
the kind of questions I wanted
to answer were the questions
that had been asked by Karl Marx.
And I understood he was kind
of an economist of some kind
so I'd better read up on economics
and see if I could understand the world.
So that's how I got into economics.
- And you went to Harvard
to do your graduate work
and have the sense that you
saw the importance of economics
but also of the institutions that surround
the focus on economic institutions.
- Well that's putting it mildly.
After my, well into my first
year, I was very disappointed
because I had gone there
'cause I wanted to understand
the way the world worked
in terms of the inequalities
and the kinds of deprivations
that that people had.
And I wasn't getting any of that.
And I decided that I wanted
to study something else
and I was so busy as a grad student
I wasn't very well prepared,
that I didn't really have time to apply
to any other programs.
I did go over to the anthropology
department at Harvard.
I was very strongly discouraged
from even taking a course or two there.
- [Harry] By the economics people.
- By the economics people, yeah.
They didn't think this
was really a very wise way
to spend my time.
- be corrupted.
- And so you know then I
just kind of stuck it out
out of inertia and so
I became an economist.
I got a degree and I was
fortunate to get a job at Harvard.
And so at that point I was more able
to chart my own course and
actually teach my own courses.
I was allowed to teach
a course on inequality
over some opposition of my colleagues
who initially said it wasn't economics.
So then I was off and running.
- At Harvard were there any mentors,
either in economics or
outside of economics,
that were congruent with the
kind of the bug that you had?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- There absolutely were.
And the first person I taught
with was Wassily Leontief,
a Russian, an inventor
of what's called input-output analysis
in economics, a mathematical technique
which I had used in my dissertation.
A second was Alexander
Gerschenkron, an economic historian.
And these were, these
people were guiding me,
supporting me, particularly Gerschenkron.
I was very interested in economic history.
Another person who I learned
a tremendous amount from was
Simon Kuznets considered to
be an economic historian.
Now the amazing coincidence is all three
of them are Russians and they
were great intellectuals.
They were the people who
I thought really were
what I imagined it would
be like to be a scholar
and I wasn't that impressed
with the other members of the faculty
but I learned a lot there.
But I after having such a good start,
I almost left economics because I realized
that most of my colleagues
we're not addressing problems
that I thought were what
economists should be addressing.
And by that time it's late 60s, 68,
I'm concerned about how
schools are organized.
Why they essentially do so little
to enhance people's ability
to lead a flourishing life
and often it seemed to be so repressive
to the students and for
the teachers involved.
I was very concerned about war,
of course the Vietnam War
was going on at the time,
and always about inequality.
And the thing that happened to me
that both almost drove me out of economics
but in the end really put me back was
I had known Dr. Martin Luther King
because I'd been part of
an organizing campaign
against the Vietnam War.
And we had asked Dr. King
along with Benjamin Spock
to come and sort of kick off
our drive, the baby doctor,
and we had them going down the street,
knocking on doors and so on.
And during that time I
was taking Dr. King around
and so he knew that there were
some economists at Harvard
that were interested in the
kind of issues he was raising.
You know, Harry, towards
the end of his life
he was organizing the Poor People's March
and he was shifting not
from just civil rights
but to economic rights.
And so he wrote or his
staff wrote and asked
if I could answer a bunch of
questions about the economy
as kind of background papers for the March
and I was thrilled.
Imagine, can you imagine,
Dr. King's and I ask you to do something
about this you know to provide
some scholarly background.
That's why I studied economics.
And finally I was gonna get to do it.
So I got the letter and I opened it up
and I was feeling quite proud of myself
that I was gonna get to do this
until I read the questions.
And I read them and they
were damn good questions,
that's the good news.
The bad news was I didn't have a clue
about how to answer them.
I was incapable.
I didn't even know where to look.
Nothing in my economics training
had given me the background
that would say okay, here's
where you'll find that out
and here's how you might
approach that problem.
And I was teaching courses
which were very heavy in mathematics.
I mean be called mathematical
economics, I guess.
And I remember being very ashamed.
And I thought, well you know
this isn't what I wanted to be
and then I said, well wait,
I've got a lot of friends,
a lot of grad students working with me,
a couple young faculty members.
Let's put a group together
and see if we can respond.
And we did.
We did almost nothing else for 10 days
and we wrote a bunch of background papers.
I remember I wrote one about education
and what could be done
to serve the interests
of less well-off and working-class people
in the school system.
And that really did it for me.
I thought, oh wow I can
do this as an economist
and then I just never
turned back, that was it.
- And give us an example
of one of the questions
that King was asking.
- Well, one of the questions
was about education,
how to pursue the objective of equality
of educational opportunity,
what that might mean.
And another question
was about reparations,
that is what would be
the appropriate magnitude
of reparations to people
of color in America
particularly former slaves.
And then interestingly he
asked what are other examples
in which there have been major subsidies
or handouts to particular groups
and what would the magnitude of those.
And so we looked at all kinds
of massive payment subsidies
to railroads and so on.
Another had to do with
the the white flight
from the central part of the city
and the suburbanization of jobs.
And I forget the others.
But it was, I mean I
learned more in that 10 days
then I think I learned in grad school.
- Looking at your career
I think it's fair to say
that you are a reformist within economics.
You want to get, you want
to be a practicing economist
but you want to think about the problems
that are not being addressed.
And so what the story you're
telling provides a link
because both your background obviously
but also that did an activist,
a brilliant activist,
Dr. King was asking you
questions that came out
of his activism and you were saying
or you were finding economics
couldn't give you the answers.
- Yeah.
I think reformist is, I'm
not exactly sure it's right
because certainly in the
70s I decided that this,
I mean I was teaching
what's called the advanced
microeconomics course
for grad students.
And that's kind of this citadel
of the conventional wisdom in economics.
And I remember when I had a sabbatical
and I decided I would go
to the Economics Institute in
Havana to teach a course there
on economic planning,
mathematical methods
for economic planning.
I remember quite triumphantly
I went to the chair of the department,
he was a very kind gentleman.
And I said and I'd been teaching
this course for some years
and it had been regarded
as quite successful
'cause I'd actually engage the students
in some difficult mathematical tool making
and tool building for them.
And I said well that's the end,
I'm not gonna teach any more of that
and I used a profane word.
I'm not teaching any more of that
and I'm gonna do something else.
And in a way that actually happened.
When I came back I started
teaching courses on inequality
and I had, so I'd made a turn
but I really did reject
the standard models
that I had been teaching that
were part of the discipline.
I taught a lot about Marxian economics,
partly as a process whereby
I could learn a lot more
about the insights of Marx.
And I looked at other ways of
developing economic reasoning.
And now I think that what's
happened is not so much
that I reformed economics
but I think economics reformed itself.
So that I'm now a lot closer
to the conventional economics
of today than I was then
because economics itself
has changed so much.
- I like to ask my guests often,
what their suggestions are about
how students should prepare
to do the kind of work that you do.
And let's talk about that
because when you look at your work
it's really interdisciplinary,
it's cross-cultural,
it's increasingly
dealing with experiments.
Talk little about how that
evolved in your career
and what advice then that
leads you to give to students.
- Well talking to economic students about,
which I know the most,
I often am asked by people
who want to be engaged with the world.
And by the way, I think the vast majority
of economics grad students
come to grad school
with some kind of a passion,
some kind of curiosity about something
and wanting to better the world.
So I think the, and then
the question is well,
how do you do that and how do you do that
and do good research.
Well the first thing
that you have to learn
as a young researcher is,
a piece of research is gonna
be published in a good journal.
It isn't going to deal
with the whole problem.
It's gonna deal with a little piece of it
and there's nothing wrong with that.
And I would never criticize
the journals for requiring us
in publishing our papers
to do a very careful job,
sometimes on very narrow topics.
The problem when you're that age is
that the thing you'd really like
to be doing is writing a book.
A book which lays out some
kind of argument and so on
and the time will come for that.
You can do it.
I did it long before I had tenure.
But that was at a time when
the job market was really good
and people weren't as scared
about what you're doing.
But learning some good research tools,
learning how to define a research problem,
that's something which people
think it's somehow too narrow.
Well, I'm sorry, it's not too narrow.
You're part of a whole
process and it accumulates
and it's fantastic what's happened
in the last 30 or 40 years in economics
because a lot of just
hard work, paper by paper,
it didn't look like it added up too much
but then when you look at 30 years,
the whole profession has changed.
And in terms of how it sees the basics,
like what are we like as people,
how do we describe us, how
do we interact in society,
these are all things
that have changed now,
in how economics is done.
Unfortunately the public
perception of economics is still
it's basically about supply and demand
and money and that kind of thing.
But we've really moved on.
- And is interdisciplinary
work the key to the changes
that are going on within economics itself?
- No, it's interesting, Harry,
what I think happened was in economics
some changes took place for,
I don't mean any disrespect,
but for rather nerdy reasons.
I mean people were just
pursuing their research
and it turned out that
things didn't fit right
and so we had to make these adjustments.
I'll explain what I mean
about that in a minute.
But the changes in economics led
to a description of the
economy which was incomplete
without interdisciplinary input.
So the interdisciplinarity
was a consequence
of the changes in economics
not a cause of it.
Now, here's an example.
One of the things that
economists now recognize is that
if you and I have a contract for example,
suppose you employ me to do a job.
Well, you can require that I come on time,
you can even require that
I obey your instructions.
But there's no way in the world
that you can write a
contract about exactly
what I'm supposed to do unless I happen
to be doing a very routine job.
But if I'm, for example,
caring for your kids
or doing scientific research
or waiting on tables
in your restaurant or just about any other
of the massive number of
jobs in the service economy,
you can't write down
what I'm supposed to do.
You've got to get me to
do it some other way.
Now our description of that
in economics is the
contract is incomplete.
It's incomplete because you have to pay me
and I have to show up.
That's not what's going
to make profits for you.
What's gonna make profits for
you is me doing something.
Now why does that get
interdisciplinarity on the table?
Well if the contract was complete,
if you had essentially
written down exactly
what I had to do if I didn't do it,
you wouldn't pay me.
And so there's or if you had paid me
you could even get my wages back
by going to court.
Now if the contract's incomplete,
what do you have to hope?
You have to hope one of two things.
One is that I have a work
ethic which leads me to
as a matter of pride or commitment
or my obligation to you to do a good job.
So my morality, my social
norms become important to you
because you can't get
me to work otherwise,
'cause you can't force me to do it.
The only other thing that
matters is your power over me
which you may have because actually
it's a pretty good job you gave me
and if you fire me I'm out of luck,
I'm on the street.
And unlike the models of supply and demand
where the curves always cross
that what that means the curves cross is
it means supply equals demand.
What that means to me, who you just fired,
is I can walk across the
street and get a job,
equivalent job somewhere else.
Now if I can do that, make my day.
I don't care Harry, fire me,
I'm going across the street.
Right, so you get the problem.
Now, so how can you avoid that?
You better pay me more than
I can get on my next job
or there'd better be some unemployment
so maybe I won't get
another job for a while.
That means you're gonna
have some power over me
and the only way you
get me to work is either
if I want to do it for moral reasons
or if I'm scared of getting fired
or some combination of the two.
Immediately you get on
the table social norms
which means sociology,
you get the exercise in power
which means political science.
So you immediately get
Durkheim on the table
and you get the great political scientists
who have studied power like Robert Dahl,
they're included now.
And notice this is not interdisciplinarity
because I'm interested in
something that sociologists study,
it's not 'cause I think
we should be broader
and I should be studying things
that other disciplines study.
What I'm saying is that if you
want to be a good economist
you'd better learn some sociology
and some political science
because modern economic,
micro economic theory,
as taught in grad schools is
about strategic interactions
in which social norms and
the exercise of power is
an intrinsic part of the story.
- In philosophy of theory let's say,
you propose a theory that simplifies,
that make certain assumptions
that clarifies a particular
part of the universe
and what you're suggesting now is that
as the economy changes
that economics has had to adapt
because the power of its
theory is being reduced.
Is that a fair restatement?
- I think that's right.
But I don't think that economics changed
because the economy changed.
I think the economics that we had really
from the most of the past century,
the microeconomics was simply,
I mean people criticize
it 'cause it's too simple
and they criticize it 'cause
it's too mathematical.
I don't agree with either of those things.
I criticize it 'cause it was wrong.
That is it was the wrong
benchmark, the wrong abstractions,
the wrong simplifications
that lead us away
from understanding things.
Because of the assumption, for example,
the supply always equals demand
because of the assumption
that you can get me to work
just by writing a contract and so on.
Those are fundamentally wrong assumptions
about how markets work.
Now, of course, the economy is changing
and it's a good thing that
economics has also changed
because the old models
they might have worked okay
in factories where you
could regulate my speed
by the speed of the assembly
line or something like that.
But they don't work at all in the examples
that I gave whereby the quality
of the job well done
is very hard to define.
For example, if I'm caring for your kids
or if I'm an elementary
school teacher and so on.
So, true, the economy is changing
and fortunately I think
economics is going to keep up
because it's changing too in terms
of the way we see our
microeconomic theory.
- Your book The Moral Economy,
which I can show to our audience,
in reading it that's what led me
to find a word to describe you
because you are grappling
with some of the concepts
and showing as you just did
with regard to contracts
that they are inadequate
in helping us understand the
richness of the environment
in which the economy operates.
- Yeah, that's right.
- And so what also emerges
in this book is a sort
of a dual way of looking at the world.
One in terms of incentives
which fits the traditional model
and for which there are
well-developed concepts in economics
but on the other hand other factors,
particularly social norms,
that focus on things like equality,
reciprocity, altruism, and so on.
Talk a little about that
because what you're saying
is we economists assumed
that incentives dealt with it all.
But in fact what this book shows is
that there is a crowding
out of these other virtues.
- That's right or in many cases
there is that crowding out.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- I want to tell you a
story about that book
because I know you're interested in
how people do their work.
I started that book in 1989.
I must have started it before then
because the first paper I
gave summarizing the content
of this book was in 1989.
I remember very well it was
in the philosophy department
in the University College London
and at the time the
paper was well received.
But I wasn't happy with it.
I didn't think it was very convincing.
And so in the intervening
decades I engaged
in doing some experiments
on human behavior
and a lot of other people much better
at experiments than I, did the same.
And so there was an
accumulation of evidence
and at the same time I decided that some
of the philosophical
foundations I that had used
in the paper weren't really very adequate.
And so I, for example, I
intensively read Machiavelli
from whom I learned a great deal.
I was able to read him in Italian
'cause I was at the
time teaching in Italy.
So that process just
went on for a long time
until I was finally happy
with the the outcome.
But an important intervening
step was the following
and I'd like to convey
this again to those of you
who are listening who are
students or young researchers.
I didn't know what tools I
would need to write that book.
I knew I had a question
and the question is
how do our preferences and values change
as a result of the economic environment
in which we function.
Now shortly after I had that
kind of false start in London,
I started to think well who
could help me with that?
And the first idea I
had was, well you know,
I think our values are a
little bit like our accents.
There are things we acquire at a young age
but like our accents if we work at it
we can change them too.
But we probably don't that much.
And I knew that their
study of language use was
very highly advanced and quantitative.
So I reached out to a bunch of
scholars in sociolinguistics
to see what I could learn from them.
And the other thing I
thought was I wondered
if there wasn't an analogy
to a biological evolution
that is the way particular
traits are favored
through higher fitness.
I wondered if there wasn't
a cultural analogy to that
and so I reached out, these
are people I didn't know,
I just wrote letters,
that's back in the days
where we wrote letters.
I wrote letters to some biologists
in the field of population genetics
and some others who were applying
those models in anthropology.
Now notice I didn't ask a single economist
because I didn't think there
was an answer in economics
'cause I knew the field pretty well.
But I did think I might
find answer elsewhere
and sure enough it worked out.
The socio linguistics part
didn't pan out very well
but the biology part of
the anthropology became
really important in my
being able to establish,
I think a basic understanding
of the following.
It's possible and I think likely
that humans beings evolved
not simply culturally
but also genetically with a predisposition
to be altruistic towards others.
Now that's a shocking statement
'cause among biologists it
was thought to be impossible
because of course the
survival of the fittest means
the survival of the selfish
according to most biologists.
So I had to do some hard work in biology
and I spent a decade and a 1/2
learning population genetics,
studying natural selection,
developing mathematical models
of the process and developing a way
of understanding natural selection
in which it's quite likely,
and I think given the evidence probable
that humans developed a genetic
predisposition towards that,
I say, generous ethical
and altruistic behavior.
Now that brings me back to this book.
Once I had done that I
did most of that work
with Herbert Gintis but also
with other collaborators,
I asked myself, well
if that's really true,
shouldn't we go back
and rethink economics?
And there's a field in economics
called behavioral economics
which has demonstrated
using behavioral experiments
that people have probably
really are generous
and when it comes to dividing
up real money and so on.
And it's kind of a boutique
field if you know what I mean.
It's ghettoized and students
can take it if they want
and it's kind of, it's cool,
but it's not really central.
And I thought now wait a minute,
if that's really what people are like
then economics has got to change a lot
and not just some field
over there on the side.
A paradigm into social sciences
has to answer questions
about what are we like,
what is society like,
how do we interact?
You know different disciplines
will do it differently
but if something fundamental
about how what we're like has changed
well then it probably has ramifications.
And so then I decided what I would do
as I've already said,
I don't think I'm that great
a behavioral economist.
I'm not very good at designing experiments
but what I thought I might do is see,
well suppose those results were true
and taken on board how would
economics look different?
How would ordinary
microeconomics, public economics,
labor economics, international trade,
history, philosophy and economics
how would all of that change?
So that's basically the
last couple of decades
that's been what what I have done
with a rather large research team
of very talented collaborators.
And this book is an example
of that trying to say,
okay, let's think again about incentives
and what we show in the
book is that incentives are
of course essential to
running a modern economy
but in many circumstances
they don't work very well.
And the reason why they don't work well is
if, imagine you've got a problem
and you want people to do the right thing.
Say, for example, that
parents are coming late
to pick up their kids at a daycare center.
And now you could jawbone them
and say well come on you ought to show up
and or you could fine them if
they don't show up on time.
And so a lot of things you could do.
Now interestingly a couple of economists
who tried an experiment in Haifa, Israel,
in which parents were coming
late to pick up their kids
it was a chain of daycares,
there were 13 of them.
And they so they decided
what they would do is
they would impose a fine
and because this would be an experiment
they imposed a fine in
half of the schools,
half the daycare centers
and not on the others.
So that others would be the control group.
And what they found is really, I mean,
they just put a notice on the door
and said as of tomorrow if you come late
you're gonna be fined a certain amount.
And no explanation was given
but I guess the parents understood.
And then they'd recorded how
many people are coming late
at all these daycare centers
and they imposed this fine
and then they recorded what happened.
Well, I mean, I wouldn't
be telling you this
if what happened is what
they thought would happen
which is they'd stop coming late.
In the daycare centers in
which the fine was imposed,
the number of people coming late doubled.
Where the fine was imposed
In the other in the control
group nothing happened.
So how do you interpret that?
Why did the fine make people come later?
Well there are a lot of
possible ways to interpret this
but the most parsimonious
I think is very simple
which is if you put a price
on something people say,
oh I can buy it, lateness
is a commodity I can buy.
I'll step right up and buy
some if it's convenient for me.
Now of course you may think, well, okay,
if they charge $100 for coming late
they probably would have come on time.
Of course they would have
but that's beside the point.
There's of course some fine
that will get them to shape up.
But a fine of a normal amount,
of the type that they did,
actually had the effect
of changing the type of problem it was.
It was no longer a problem like shopping
in which it's perfectly okay
to try to get a good deal.
I mean it was no longer a problem
like dealing with your
neighbor or your family
in which there's some
moral or ethical reason
that goes into you should try
to be respectful and so on.
It turned it into, by
putting a price on it,
it turned it into a shopping problem.
Do the best you can according
to the dollars and cents dimension.
And for some people it
was worth it to come late.
But every night I know some people
neither you nor I would ever do this
but I know people who
routinely park illegally
and they say, hey, it's only $25.
So that's the price of parking illegally
and that once it's seen as a price
you have no moral obligation
as long as you're willing
to pay the ticket.
- One of the things I wanted
to point out in your book
which relates to what
you're talking about is that
you go through the history
of economic thinking
in defining incentives.
And what again and again you
show is there was a nugget
of truth in what the great thinker said
and then it was ignored basically.
And so in the book you were taking
these assumptions, for example,
what you just discussed,
separability, the notion
that you could separate
or you're just doing
this to use incentives
and it doesn't affect the moral issues.
So it's really challenging
traditional theory
and informing it with careful thinking
about what the implications are
of particular pieces of a theory.
- That's right, and you
look at the great economists
and you think now wait a minute.
Did they really get it that wrong?
Were they really so stupid as to think
that we respond to incentives
but there are not other kinds
of reasons for our behavior?
No, of course they were not that stupid.
Adam Smith is well known to have written,
The Wealth of Nations, but he also wrote,
The Theory of Moral Sentiments.
Machiavelli, who's often quoted
as if people are just selfish
and wicked as he called them,
goes on and on about the
essential role of social norms
and values in good governance.
So if you read carefully
what they're saying,
these are wise, wise people who understand
that incentive play an important role
but also social norms
and we have to think of
the two of them together.
What they missed was the fact
that you can't separate the two
as if you can you have a dial over here
and you can crank up the
incentives a little bit
and then you might also
have religion over here
and crank up people's
social norms and so on.
It's as if the two dials aren't connected
but it turns out if you
turn this dial up too much
you're gonna diminish
some of the importance
of the social preferences
and ethical reasoning in some cases.
Now I want to say, there's
a whole lot of jobs
in the modern economy that only work
'cause people are paid well to do them
because people have no
reason to do them otherwise.
That's unfortunate, it's too bad
that our economy has a lot of jobs
which people don't have
an engagement with.
But I don't mean to suggest
that we shouldn't use incentives
where we can dispense with them.
Of course we cannot.
But we should understand
that when incentives are used
in a way that either dominates
a person or exploits them,
you're gonna get a negative reaction
if the person has some freedom
to choose a negative reaction
and we see that in the experiments
and we see it in real life.
- You are involved in
helping to lead a project
which is trying to transform economics
with a new curriculum
which is available online universally.
Talk a little about that.
- Well this is a project that started,
it's probably influenced by
the 2008 financial crisis
but it had been brewing in the minds
of a lot of us for a while.
And it was the, someone
initially called it, the project,
economics as if the last
30 years had happened.
Now it wasn't just the last
30 years of the economy
it was the last 30 years of economics.
We began to to notice
that what was going on
in the intro classrooms in you
know EC10, had nothing to do
with what we were
teaching our grad students
and it had nothing to do with
how we were talking amongst
each other researchers
about the kind of economics
that we do and think about.
So the intro courses were teaching
extraordinarily out of date,
not up to the frontiers of
economics kind of reasoning.
And this happens from time to time.
The great physicist Feynman in the 60s
when he was teaching at Caltech
he had the same realization
which is that the physics students then
they wanted to learn about
things about nuclear energy,
the frontiers of physics
and what were they getting,
levers and incline planes
and all kinds of stuff like that.
And maybe at the end of a course
or at the late in your major
you might get something
about modern physics.
Well what Feynman decided to do is,
let's put the new stuff
in the front of the book
instead of the back of the book
and we thought, yeah,
why don't we do that.
Why don't we give the undergrads,
obviously a much simplified
introductory version
to what we now teach our PhD students.
And so that was our first
idea that we should do that.
And the second thing is
the economics of today
in the intro classroom appears
to have almost nothing to do
with why the students are
there in the first place.
Listen to this.
Around the world, we're
a global organization.
Around the world we have
done over and over again
we go to a classroom of people
who it's their first course in economics
and before anything,
before we say anything,
we say please take out a piece of paper
and write on the paper what do
you think economists should,
what issues should economists
be addressing today.
I should have brought it here, Harry,
because we make word clouds of these.
And the size of the font is indicating
how common the word is used.
Well the first time we
did this we were amazed.
It was at University College in London
and these were as they
say first year students,
never heard about economics
and the word inequality is
this big in the word cloud.
And then there is climate change
and then there's other
words like instability.
Interestingly, this is in 2016,
this big was the word Donald
Trump who the students,
the beginning students thought
was an economic problem
that would have to be addressed.
When we did it later the students there
in UK would write Brexit
as a really big one.
But around the world inequality is giant
in these word clouds.
And it's very, very
similar wherever you go.
Now when we mentioned this to some people
they said well, yeah, a bunch
of left-of-center students
that's what you got there.
So we tried it once at
the Bank of England.
The head of this project, Wendy
Carlin, a professor at UCL,
regularly goes to the Bank of England.
She's an adviser to parts
of the British government
and so she was going to give a talk
to the incoming recruits.
They're almost a hundred of them,
almost all of them successful
economics graduates
who decided to go on in finance.
So she did the same thing with them
and if I showed you that word cloud
you would not be able to pick it out.
Same thing inequality this
big, climate change and so on.
We did it at the Central Bank and Treasury
in Wellington, New Zealand.
We got the same answer with
a 120 professional economists
in the business of finance.
That's what people think
economics should be doing.
Do you find that in the textbooks?
Well maybe in chapter 34
which you never get to.
They say it's good reading for the beach.
So in our book we start with,
here's what's going on in the world
and we look at what we call
the capitalist revolution,
this extraordinary thing that happened
when capitalism occurred
which is income per capita
in the world had been
going along like this
for almost a thousand
years in which we have data
and it went almost vertical.
It looks vertical on a graph in the UK
after that some other places Japan,
finally belatedly, India and China.
We call that the capitalist revolution.
And we think that's associated
with these countries
essentially experiencing
what we call the capitalist revolution
but that's also what made
the world highly unequal
between the countries
that were rich and poor
and also that's what,
and we present evidence on climate change.
That's what now imperils
the entire entire humanity
because of climate change.
That's what they get in the first chapter.
Now notice what's gonna happen.
If you put that stuff
in the first chapter,
you're gonna have to
change the rest of the book
because you can't just be
teaching them supply and demand
and then expect that
they're gonna understand
why capitalism took off, why
our climate is endangered,
why the world is so unequal and so on.
- So let's give our audience the URL,
core-econ, E-C-O-C, .org.
And there's an online
textbook, there's a curriculum
and there seems to be a lively discussion
about issues emerging in
newspaper articles and so on.
So this seems to suggest
that the young people,
maybe people in general are more attuned
to the problems we need to confront
but the institution of
economics departments,
not necessarily individual,
are not adapting
and the new technology provides a way
to put something out there
that everybody can reach
that can help address this problem.
- Yeah, that's right.
I mean it's been extraordinary
how this thing has taken off.
I mean, I wish I had my phone on me,
I would just show you that
you can get it on your phone,
you can get it on any device
and people are doing it
all around the world.
And we're getting, I mean,
just recent, just two days ago,
a person from Georgia wants
to translate it into Georgian,
it's being translated into Farsi
and you name the language it's happening.
And because it's online, it's digital,
you can do adaptations.
Now what absolutely shocked us was that
this new intro course
almost immediately displaced
the standard intro course
at the top economics
departments in Europe,
at the University College London,
at the Toulouse School of
Economics at Sciences Po in Paris,
Humboldt University in Berlin.
They went over almost instantly.
We weren't even ready, they
were just using a beta version
that was online and they went for it
and that suggests that
economics is ready to change.
And it's also, I think a lot of the,
I mean one of the reasons
why we've been successful is
that this is a very unusual organization.
It's a global collaboration of researchers
from all over the world
who contributed content.
A small editorial group
has given it a common voice
and nobody's been paid.
None of the content
providers have been paid,
it's a collaborative, it's
a cooperative organization.
Obviously we had to pay to
build a good platform for it.
Check it out, it's an
outstanding platform.
And we had help from
designers in Bangalore,
the platform was developed
in a very outstanding group in Cape Town
and we have a very small staff,
one full-time member of the staff
and it's a huge volunteer organization.
So there's a lesson there.
What it means is as we move
into the modern economy
of knowledge, creation and distribution,
maybe we should think about different ways
of organizing our production.
That is that's what we teach
in part of the curriculum.
There are different ways of
organizing how we do things
and it occurred to us,
well, we're an example.
We're an example because we have no,
that is, we have this
available free online.
It's a Creative Commons license
because we don't believe
that knowledge should be a commodity.
And so we're actually,
we belatedly realized,
oh we're doing the economics
that we're teaching.
- One final question
requiring a very short answer
because our time is out.
So that middle schooler
in India asking his mother
what's the difference
here, why aren't you know,
why is there so much poverty?
One element of your journey,
your intellectual journey
that stands out to you
for answering that question,
over time, in your own way.
- Well I think I've been
fortunate in having teachers
who were interested in history
and taught me the
importance of institutions.
It's an important part of
modern economics today,
it has roots in the economics
of Karl Marx and Adam Smith.
Those are the people who
have given me the tools
to understand now a little better
why India was then so
poor compared to America
and why India is rapidly changing now
along with China, Vietnam
and some other countries.
So I've been very fortunate
to live in this period of time
and to have teachers who
allowed me to take that route.
And I can't say I have a good answer
but I have a better
answer than my mom had.
- Well on that note, Sam, I
want to thank you very much
for coming to the campus
delivering the Weinstock lecture
and being on our program.
- Thank you very much, Harry.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(dramatic music)